[Musica]
vorrei iniziare questa chiacchierata con
voi dando un po' di numeri visto che
sono una psicoterapeuta soprattutto 36 e
60 che per me sono significativi 60 sono
i chilometri
di distanza fra Colleferro dove sono
nata e Roma dove mi sono trasferita con
il mio diploma di infermiera
professionale in tasca e ho iniziato a
stare accanto alle persone che lottavano
per continuare a vivere
36 sono gli anni trascorsi accanto alle
persone che soffrivano di questi 16 li
ho trascorso in una terapia intensiva e
rianimazione dove ho imparato
sicuramente a gestire lo stress lo
sconforto A volte anche la disperazione
ma anche a gioire per un bip in più
e ad assaporare il valore della vita
In quegli anni sono arrivate la laurea
in psicologia e le varie
specializzazioni e la decisione di
diventare psicoterapeuta
non è un caso Come spesso accade che poi
mi si è occupata prevalentemente appunto
di coppie ma è stata piuttosto la mia
frustrazione di figlia di genitori
separati e la voglia e gli inutili
tentativi di riparare il loro Cocci
Nel frattempo sono diventata anche madre
proprio nel momento in cui ho smesso di
essere figlia nascita e morte si sono
intrecciate E hanno anche cambiato il
mio modo di stare accanto alle persone
nella vita e anche nella professione
anche qui non è un caso che abbia sempre
sognato di trovare il principe azzurro
probabilmente la disfatta della coppia
genitoriale mi ha portato a sognare da
sempre e vi chiederei quante di voi
hanno sognato almeno una volta nella
vita di trovare un principe azzurro
Romanticismo
e quanti di voi maschietti hanno sognato
almeno una volta di essere quel Principe
Azzurro non mi deludete
ora Purtroppo succede spesso che il
principe azzurro Oggi meglio
identificato come maschio Alfa
spesso appunto Da bravo lupo ci faccia
sentire più come Cappuccetto Rosso
diciamo e succede anche che le
principesse baciando i loro principi
azzurri li trasformino in un rospo
a questo punto dobbiamo chiederci Ma
esiste ancora l'istituzione coppia
basata sull'amore
o dobbiamo rassegnarci di fronte ai dati
così sconfortanti relativi alle
separazioni ai divorzi Insomma io ne
vedo molte di coppie sfrante nel mio
studio
vi spoilero Il finale non è così
semplice
credo che oggi la coppia sia in crisi lo
vediamo tutti come istituzione e che sia
lanciando effettivamente l'ennesimo SOS
laddove stavolta l'acronimo s o s sta
per sesso obblighi sentimenti
sono i tre cardini su cui si fonda una
coppia d'amore così la possiamo definire
la nostra coppia
ora per fare un viaggio interessante
nella nostra coppia Avrei bisogno della
diapositiva giusta
e cioè
Ecco
vorrei ricordarvi il mito della caverna
di Platone giusto Appunto
il mito della caverna di Platone
fondamentalmente ci insegna che a volte
rimaniamo Prigionieri di un'illusione
la coppia che vediamo qui è proprio come
quei prigionieri della caverna
ha davanti a sé delle ombre proiettate e
le scambia per una realtà perché è
incatenata di fronte a queste ombre cosa
rappresentano queste ombre rappresentano
le ombre di un passato emotivo non
risolto spesso caratterizzato dal senso
di abbandono
da traumi relativi all'attaccamento con
la figura materna di riferimento
oppure
percepiscono i pregiudizi rispetto
all'educazione sessuale ricevuta e
continuano a guardare imperterriti solo
davanti a loro non rendendosi conto che
la realtà oggettiva Non è quella D'altra
parte non hanno modo di vedere dietro di
loro Da dove derivano queste ombre
queste illusioni e vanno avanti spesso
per molto molto tempo anche anni
soffrendo soffrendo
fino a che questa sofferenza non diventa
estrema e allora li spinge fuori dalla
caverna Finalmente si liberano
Ma fuori dalla caverna se vogliamo è
ancora peggio perché fondamentalmente la
luce è accecante e la realtà esterna è
spiazzante hanno consapevolezza di aver
sofferto probabilmente di cose
Assolutamente razionali ma sono anche
molto affaticati da questo
la prossima
fuori dalla caverna
è così spiazzante la situazione che
l'idea è quasi quella di tornare
indietro in quel luogo buio ma comunque
conosciuto
E comunque la consapevolezza non è
sufficiente per portare la coppia alla
guarigione è importante a questo punto
la terapia o perlomeno la teoria della
coppia che ci dice appunto che una
coppia sana si basa su questi tre
Cardini Il sesso gli obblighi e i
sentimenti che adesso andremo a vedere
Direi di partire dal sesso che ne dite
forse l'elemento per molti di noi più
importante
ma il sesso non è la cosa più importante
perché gli ingredienti hanno pari
dignità
la sessualità è sicuramente un bisogno
primario dell'uomo ma oggi Il sesso è
mitizzato volgarizzato È un'ossessione
intrisa di luoghi comuni e se non è alla
base della crisi di coppia ne subisce
sicuramente gli effetti devastanti
Tuttavia la sessualità pur essendo un
bisogno primario è un qualcosa che si
attiva in età adolescenziale Grazie
all'azione degli ormoni Ma va di pari
passo con quello che è l'attaccamento
emotivo e affettivo rispetto alle figure
primarie per cui se c'è stato un danno
un elemento diciamo negativo sullo stile
di attaccamento emotivo ed affettivo
anche la sessualità ne risentirà
d'altra parte le coppie più datate hanno
al loro interno una sessualità noiosa
spesso solo strumentale
ad avere ad ottenere uno sfogo fisico
oppure un contatto emotivo affettivo che
non riescono ad avere più fuori dalla
sessualità la passione Oggi è un
qualcosa che è diventato un imperativo
se il matrimonio non resiste
in assenza della passione
fondamentalmente
viene meno tutto
quindi
è importante non dare troppa rilevanza
alla sfera della sessualità ma pensare a
queste tre componenti come integrate
e in effetti le coppie che hanno
superato quella prima fase
dell'innamoramento che è la fase
illusoria fondamentalmente sanno che è
molto importante un altro elemento della
coppia che sono gli obblighi ho voluto
utilizzare appositamente questa parola
un po' dura ma perché l'ho voluto
utilizzare nel suo vero senso e cioè il
debito di riconoscenza il senso di
gratitudine verso l'altro per il bene
ricevuto
Non possiamo Non parlare a proposito di
obblighi dell'obbligo fondamentale
all'interno della coppia ossia La
fedeltà Ecco anche la fedeltà vorrei
intenderla nella sua forma attiva non
passiva vorrei intendere La fedeltà come
una scelta quotidiana una scelta che
comporta una rinuncia ma tanto più è
alto il valore della rinuncia Tanto più
è nobile il valore della scelta
rinnovata
e infine parlerei dei sentimenti
l'amore non esiste se non c'è alla base
la stima la fiducia e il rispetto troppe
volte sento parlare di Amore senza
queste componenti i sentimenti sono
sicuramente alla base
dell'intimità psicologica Sono
alla base della
gradevolezza dello stare in coppia
anche questi però vanno coltivati
perché fondamentalmente ci sono persone
che riescono con molta facilità a
nutrire fiducia e a dare valore
all'altro Ma ci sono anche persone che
non riescono da che cosa dipende questo
anche qui ci viene in aiuto la teoria
dell'attaccamento di John bowlby
che ci dice che fondamentalmente lo
schema della fiducia verso l'altro si
basa molto presto fin dalla nascita
direi fin dal primo momento in cui ci
rapportiamo con la figura che noi
definiamo caregiver
che ci fa sentire di poter essere
fiduciosi verso l'altro Ecco anche qui
purtroppo le recenti ricerche dimostrano
che una buona parte della popolazione
sviluppa uno stile di attaccamento
insicuro ora che sia ambivalente
disorganizzato o evitante non ci importa
la cosa fondamentale è che i soggetti
insicuri tendono ad accoppiarsi tra di
loro
coltivando l'illusione di poter trovare
nell'altro ciò che non hanno la stima
per loro stessi oppure di vedere l'altro
come nella possibilità di lenire le
proprie ferite del passato Ecco anche
queste coppie sono destinate miseramente
a fallire una volta terminata la fase
dell'innamoramento oppure addirittura
non decollano mai veramente
D'altra parte invece i soggetti sicuri
si scelgono fra di loro dando vita ad
una coppia sana basata sulla stima
appunto fiducia e rispetto reciproci
Ora vorrei tornare un po' a Monte di
questo discorso per darvi anche qualche
soluzione possibilmente per
salvaguardare la nostra coppia
Innanzitutto credo che sia opportuno
riflettere possibilmente insieme sul
passato emotivo
sul proprio passato emotivo non risolto
e sul passato emotivo dall'altro
farlo insieme diventa una scoperta molto
interessante che unisce ancora di più e
alimenta l'alchimia della relazione Poi
individuare eventualmente uno stile di
attaccamento non risolto non elaborato e
se possibile farlo o all'interno della
relazione oppure con l'aiuto di un
terapeuta
emanciparsi dalla famiglia di origine è
indispensabile non possiamo diventare
partner adeguati o genitori a nostra
volta se non smettiamo di essere dei
figli
e infine liberarsi banalmente dai
pregiudizi e dai tabù relativi alla
sessualità
a per la cronaca il principe azzurro io
l'ho trovato
ma è stato solo quando ho capito che non
potevo fare niente rispetto alla
relazione dei miei genitori che non ero
responsabile e pertanto non avevo da
riparare nulla grazie
[Applauso]